how's it going bros my name is bad
welcome back to some hype afraid of
monsters are you scared are you scared
I can I can tell I'm just looking at you
I'm standing it to yourself right
no why did I click this video now that
she's like period in very low pixels
anyway and last time somebody found a
friggin shotgun so I think it's about
time to tear things [ __ ] up okay bro
bro bro I get it I get it
we used to be friends but not in mark
now ah they're [ __ ] everywhere oh
holy [ __ ] I'm just gonna go even though
I have a shotgun
oh no it's the [ __ ] trying to stress
up doors or whatever [ __ ] am i painting
mr. sheriff's not about time
alright camp by the corner camp in the
[ __ ] corner it's just like FS
seize it ah ah ah don't you sperm at me
I hate you die
shotgun [ __ ] sucks Jesus Christ think
Oh again cool
hey Glock holy [ __ ] okay Peter that's
not a Glock it's an AC 3 3 - ah ha ha
you bros can come in here you're such an
idiot
holy [ __ ] I have five health though okay
hey girls some wise hey okay I think we
have to kill this thing
there we go he's dead chopped up
chocolate tough tough tough the tough
hop hop jump nothing cha cha cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha go yes
drugs I love drugs hey can I Drive this
yay let's go Wow okay no and then we get
done it hey cha cha cha cha cha
oh shut up the chapter chapter dr.
Struthers happen oh no drugs
[ __ ] why don't they leave drugs in the
boxes I don't get it cha-cha-cha top the
top ah I want my drugs
I need my drugs what's up here what is
this cha cha cha cha cha cha can't be
shopped all right we're gonna go
upstairs bring the shotgun
cuz I'm mad furious okay actually I'm
gonna use a Glock cuz you know I'm gonna
be modest what the Frick ah what up
stop it it's not valid ah Jesus Christ
what are you Jesus penis why is every
[ __ ] door jammed in this game alright
chop chop dog I see you you can stay
there I don't like you very much
chop chop okay with a [ __ ] am i top oh
oh that little [ __ ]
oh there's new monsters ah god damn I
hate you Oh F did we do this [ __ ]
alright look I forgot about you boom
boom boom gotta get that boom boom boom
gotta get what I need top that top top
top top top top top top top top top top
top give me drugs there we go thank you
sir thank you cancer now what did I do I
went here chopped that job I already
chopped those [ __ ] decoy shop objects
I don't like that very much
let's reload this [ __ ] shotgun
and then I'm not gonna see if we can
sneak up on this little [ __ ] how
chapped top
doesn't speak knife language apparently
chop-chop-chop-chop Taffet ha ha ah you
speak my shotgun BAM you like that
hey like that that means they like it
that means with girls at knees okay
oh god what the [ __ ] dude I don't want
to go there alright save here I don't
trust that at all
boom gotta get one shot and you're dead
alright let's see we should probably run
I'm just gonna go here okay get out of
my face why would I ever don't do you
okay maybe we can dodge this no this one
wants me I know you're sexing [ __ ] I
like you very much
no I do not like you very much
okay okay ah there's another father's
another one's little sneaky [ __ ] okay
one shot there dad that's good at least
all right
huh ah ah yeah ah [ __ ] let's try that
again
I think I have to kill them okay come my
bra come on ba man bra [ __ ] alright I
see you I see you I acknowledge your
existence in your dad I didn't die yeah
your dad okay good
rah rah rah rah ha bro
I see you I see you it's fine I know
you're alive now you're not all right
come on bro come on rock I see you I see
you you're happy
not anymore I was good okay there we go
thank god that's over
huh boxes so many boxes top that Tata
Tata Tata
yeah mo jumped up touch-a touch-a
touch-a touch-a touch-a touch-a touch
the top o head rogues I'm so happy
Tata Tata Tata Tata Tata oh nothing
nothing
hey chopped up chapter 10 chapter 10
photons I talked to toughen up batteries
yes I just love fun stuff in this game
all right it's time to shave
alright girls in here I don't like it
very much it's not cool [ __ ] jump in
my face there you go your dad you liked
it huh okay girl back back back
so it has a dildo in his mouth oh okay
sound when they die uh it's like the
coming but I don't know that joke is
getting old
oh this is why I try to go the last time
could save me a lot of [ __ ] animal
all right whatever you [ __ ] hate you
Oh [ __ ] fricative I have to reload
okay come on bro
it's your [ __ ] now [ __ ] who's your
[ __ ] [ __ ] now [ __ ]
who's your [ __ ] now [ __ ] let's do
[ __ ] now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] now [ __ ]
appreciation damages we're back here
alright let's see oh man someone should
count how many [ __ ] times ah I guess
my head gets shot though top top top top
he speaks my language
it's my god ah okay let's go here cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha da --duck --duck
--duck --duck --duck --duck --duck
--duck --duck --duck --duck --duck okay
I like this place I think we have to
jump through that ladder jump chop ah
that hurt me ledee I heard me okay let's
go
I save here this game really wants you
to die frictional games actually rather
an interesting blog post about dying in
a
in horror games like if you die too
often it room it route goddamnit your
counter ruins too scary in this and have
to agree there's a certain tension that
builds up if you don't die in a while
after why why are you going down what is
there an elevator crushing me yeah it is
and there goes life of PIP I think I
hurry okay look down it's kind of hard
to orient and there we go but I know I'm
in it it's impossible to see what the
[ __ ] I am in the beginning okay here we
go okay now we get it still crush this
me let's be faster than that apparently
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
ah oh and it crushes me alright I need a
[ __ ] this is difficult
come on ah goddamnit oh man how many
times PewDiePie gonna die in this
playthrough I'm getting that five
billion five billion that's a lot that's
more than two actually whoa you can see
that jump
holy [ __ ] I wonder if I can pull that
off what okay I did pull it up now
you're dead I don't like you very much
no sir yeah yeah yeah you're in pain cuz
what I did I'm not even supposed to be
here that's great came back to the
ladder I would film okay
like Sheena let's say Jesus penis Jesus
had a penis he would be like Jesus penis
got them and getting kind of sick dying
all the time but okay jump
I died come on come on bruh
yes okay we're good yes we're so [ __ ]
good save
you can't even quick say that's the
worst boy our best part I don't know why
are we supposed to go off I know almost
stoned oh it's here
oh cool and I died that's not very cool
actually maybe what's cool I don't know
I was cool before it was cool okay let's
go down down down down is there any way
I can go without dying no it doesn't
seem like it
hey Kadamba my gumbo alright I'm gonna
end up here bros hope you enjoyed I
liked it fair if you did and also your
Maura
the door won't open
alright fine oh is that creepy song give
me shiver huh Oh